[Musique]
représente robert déménageurs bretons
qui nous installe
maintenant ce fauteuil c'est vous
caroline qu'elle est passée la première
sur le fauteuil des sept péchés capitaux
on s'est toujours pudil dans cette
émission c'est pour qu'on ne se fait pas
de cadeaux sympathiques on est méchant
et on répond sincèrement qui pose la
première question très contente que je
sois dans le fauteuil en général entre
le tankiste you est l'incarnation de la
mac avec un grand f tus et sexy tu et
sensuelle je reste à voir si c'est
réellement toi c'est une partie de moi
voilà le week-end sur hanche en jogging
le matin j'ai pas de maquillage jeux
jeux forts comme comme je suis mais
c'est vrai que j'ai ce petit penchant
aider toujours eu pour les fringues
d'une certaine manière les talons le
maquillage etc
donc je suis victime moi elle est posée
par j -p c'est une question paraissent
sur ces 8 tu ne présente que des best-of
c'est parce que tu es faits niant tout
parce qu'on ne propose rien d'autre
proposent rien d'autre c'est pas l'envié
qui manque un peu ce qu'ils ont cru non
je n'en souffre pas c'est pas non plus
une souffrance atroce mais c'est vrai
que j'ai plein d'idées et on me laisse
pas toujours aller au bout de mes idées
alors il faut qu'on laisse aller francky
gérald tout le monde pourquoi francky
vincent ont fait partie d'eux
perreault ligne à si on te donnait la
possibilité de remplacer un chroniqueur
historique dans cette émission lequel
serait-il et pourquoi
ah non je remplacerais personne parce
que je trouve qu'il n'ya rien de pire
que de prendre la place de quelqu'un et
ensuite d'être assimilé à il fait moins
bien qu'il ya un nom à dire vrai
personne je peux dire que ce serait
personne je n'ai pas du tout envie de
remplacer quelqu'un parce que je trouve
que justement après on traîne cette
espèce d'image forcément mieux ou moins
bien que à la personne avant donc pas
contre l'arrivée de thibaut rolland
pourrait très bien remplacer celle de
maxime guinis locaux plus personne n'a
de questions on applaudit caroline it
[Applaudissements]